Loaned to us from NHL and New York Rangers, directly from Madison Square Garden ...
Welcome, forward Mats Zuccarello and goalkeeper Henrik Lundqvist!
It's like ... When we told our crew here who we had booked for the show ...
They were so impressed!
The Americans working here were so impressed.
Last year we had Bruce Springsteen, and that was nothing ...
... compared to you being here now.
You've got ...
... a life where you train a lot.
As far as I know, you've arrived straight from training today.
Which one of you spends the most time training?
I think it's me.
No!
It's me.
At least on a yearly basis.
It's like this.
A lot of people talk about ...
... how much you train. But the important thing is really ...
... how you train. To have a high quality training.
And that ...
I'm not saying that as a joke.
But the older you get ...
It's very important to have good quality training so you're not out there too long.
Both on the ice and in the gym, so when you're there you always have a drive.
So I guess I try to have a little more quality than Mats.
So you've got quality training, and you've got quantity training?
... But not with a very high quality?
No, the quality isn't very high. I do what's fun!
And there's not much quality in that. Usually, at least.
How is Zucca perceived ...
... in the New York Rangers? How does one speak about him, who is he?
No, but he's ... An incredibly good team mate.
Always ...
Happy, joking around, and he has a good energy ...
Works hard.
And he's been here so many years that he's also become a leader figure in the team.
It's important that players like that work as hard as him.
So he's sending out good signals.
But he likes to joke around and ...
To me, he's a little like an annoying little brother, actually.
On the ice.
Why is that?
The few times he actually scores in training, he's always raising his arms in the air while yelling, and ...
... and show everyone that he's scored a goal.
It's extremely annoying.
He's rubbing it in?
Yeah, he rubs it in. Every time!
But does that happen often, that you score?
Yeah. It's usually quite a lot.
Is it easy to score with him?
No, that's why I cheer, because I'm one of the few people in the world who can score on Henke whenever I want!
How is Henke perceived in the team?
He's «The King» for everyone else.
Yeah, he is The King.
He definitely is. He is the face of the Rangers and ...
Like he said ...
He is our best player.
He's been the Rangers' best player the last 10-12 years.
Without him, we wouldn't have the success we've had. Not that we've won, but ...
We've come a long way.
And like he says, he gets infuriated in trainings whenever someone scores, and ...
It's that instinct that he has.
Where he hates to lose, and hates to let goals in.
He never quits on a puck.
He's got the winner instinct, and that's ...
Like he said, when he's our biggest guy, it's important the he steps forward and shows that.
Especially when it's not going well. We've had a bad period and ...
... he takes charge and lets us know what he thinks, and people listen to him.
He gets upset?
He can get a little upset.
He can.
But that goes for all of us.
But who is the rest of the team most afraid of?
Of the two of you?
That would be Henrik.
He's a little ...
... further up the ladder.
When I get mad, I get mad. Yes. And it happens sometimes.
But that can be a mixed blessing.
There's a lot at stake ...
And ...
I'm thinking about before a match, when you ...
When you have to get ready.
There's ... as I've understood, a lot of rituals.
What are those rituals?
What kind of rituals do you have? What do you need to do every time?
Every time!
It's actually quite a lot.
When I get ready, I have to put on my gloves a certain way. I go through certain things in my head.
You have to take on your gloves in a certain way?
Yeah, you know, It's always the catcher first, then the mask.
I bend down, go through certain things in my head.
I'll always do the same, every time. And then ...
And then it's tome to go out there, and I'll get ready to go out there.
But that procedure ...
... always happens, within every period.
How about you?
I guess it's not as bad as him.
I can be pretty annoying and ...
... bother him a lot, but on match day, I talk to him as little as possible.
He's not so social?
Well, I'm sure he is, but I just ...
I do not want to be the reason he plays poorly.
So I stay away from him on match days.
So your ritual is really just not to speak to Henke?
Yes. On match days.
And then if we've won and he's played I might bother him for letting in a goal ...
But before matches and during those days I try to keep away ...
I let him do his own thing, so that I won't say or do anything wrong that makes him play poorly.
But I ...
I've got a few rituals.
I used to walk to the matches, because I lived quite close to Garden.
I would always walk the same route if we won.
And if we lost, I would change the woute, you know. But then ...
You become a bit crazy in the end.
So you should relax a little with those things.
So you would walk certain routes?
Yeah, I would be like «last time, I went that direction, so now I have to go a small detour». But you become ...
... crazy in the end.
So I've calmed down a little.
I put on my right skate first. It's not really a ritual, it's ...
Like Henke says, it's just a force of habit.
It's just how it's become.
And then you've got ...
With certain team mates you've got a hand shake here, and ...
... a little dance move with someone there, and then ...
The last thing ...?
What did you say?
You dance?
Yeah, we've always got music when we go out, and there's a song at the end and then ...
... there's a dance-off. And if that works, we just keep doing it until ...
... you lose, and then you change.
A couple of years ago, when we had a long winning streak, we had a dance-off ...
Four-five of the guys were dancing to techno music, and ...
Are you a part of this?
No, I'm somewhere completely different.
He's not there.
He's not mentally ...
... in the same world as us.
When I'm in my own bubble, they'll be having a dance-off.
Because you want to be by yourself?
Yes. It's like Mats says, I'm very quiet on match days.
I don't talk a lot.
So you'll be moping in the corner, while you're dancing?
I'm keeping it loose, while he's minding his own.
Can you tell me about ... Now that you're so ...
... so prominent in the team ...
It hasn't always been like that, you've both been rookies at one time ...
What's the difference?
Being a rookie in the New York Rangers, what do you have to put up with, what do you ...
It's changed a little, you notice that some of the young guys coming in, they claim things in a different way.
And our job is really to control this.
But we don't really do that, we just let it happen.
Is it a little annoying?
It's just society in general ...
But for example, if it's meal time, and then you go ...
... to get food, and there's a rookie in front of you.
Then I might say something.
And for instance when we get to the plane, and some of the young people run on the plane first ...
... and we're at the back waiting with our bags, that's like ...
Times have changed. Times have changed!
But that's ...
And you've also got those who get it. Who'll stand beside you and wait for their turn.
But that doesn't happen every time. That's how it is.
When I first joined the team as young ...
I remember the first time I trained with the Rangers, Henke wasn't there ...
And I got a text message asking if I could shoot at Henke.
I was staying at a hotel.
And I was just like «whoah, am I gonna shoot at Henke» ...
I was scared of him. I was too afraid to speak to him.
My shots were low.
Close to the ice.
I was scared of shooting higher.
But I think that's how it should be.
Because you learn to respect others ...
... and your elders.
Mats had a very serious injury.
You got a fracture in your skull.
And a bleeding in your brain.
And I'm just wondering ...
From your perspective ... I don't know if you were there when it happened?
Yeah, I played that match.
What do you remember from that incident?
Well, we didn't quite realize ....
How serious it was, when it happened.
A lot of times, hockey players will get hit by both sticks, pucks and skates ...
... and ...
I didn't quite get the full scale of it.
It wasn't before the match was over that we heard how serious it was.
Mats can explain himself, but ...
The biggest shock came when I met Mats for the first time after ...
And he had difficulties talking.
Then you really ....
«Wow. This is ...»
It could've gone worse ...
But what happened was very serious, so that was a little ...
... scary.
Did you go to the hospital?
No, we were at home with the kids. But I remember that we facetimed with our daughter.
Tried to joke around a little.
I said to him that he usually is quite a handful on the ice anyways ...
So it's quite pleasing that you can't speak right now!
I remember telling him that.
Only as a joke, of course.
And looking back, it's wonderful that everything went well, but it was scary the first weeks.
How do you look back on that incident?
Has it changed you, and has it made you more afraid?
No. I don't feel that it has.
The worst part was meeting the guys, and you could see that they just ...
What the f*ck is he ...
When I couldn't speak, I couldn't say one word and ...
So that was hard, but ...
It ended well.
As we've said, it was ...
There were a few months that were a bit harder where I couldn't move properly and ...
I couldn't speak.
I played the next season again and everything ...
Everything went well.
You two live very different lives here in New York.
You have a family life.
You don't have a family?
I have a family. I have a mother and father.
But you're a bachelor in New York, or?
Yeah. I don't have a family life like his, with kids.
So he's actually a quite boring pal?
Well, I think I would say that ...
Hockey players are pretty boring in general during season.
You play four matches a week.
And you don't have the energy to do a lot of other stuff anyways.
So you end up in the couch a lot, relaxing.
Recovering after the matches.
We're not living a jetset life.
How much time do you get on the couch, recovering and relaxing?
Well, I can remember that time from before I had kids.
But now it's crazy.
But we spend a lot of time together when we travel.
We have 41 home matches, but we also have 41 matches away from home.
So the team ends up being together. And then there's also a lot of players who have ...
... their own kids. So when you're at home, you try to ...
... spend time with them.
But the last year and a half, it's been more difficult for my oldest daughter to accept that I spend so much time away.
And she'll start crying when I leave, and I'll try to explain ...
... that it's my job and something that I want to do.
But I'll leave, and then she'll forget. But the next time she'll cry again.
I didn't realize how much we're away before I had children.
Life continued and ...
I did a lot of stuff.
But now you realize how much you're away, with the kids ...
You lose a lot of time.
I thought we could finish up here with ...
I know that you're both very competitive.
So ...
I thought it might be cool to se you in action.
But that would be a little difficult to arrange here.
But if it's okay with you guys, I've just got ...
One of those hockey games.
Can we get that in here?
And this ...
Now. Come here, come here. The thing is ...
We have got ...
Unfortunately.
We've got Rangers players.
And we've got Sweden.
Okay.
And we tried really hard to get Norway.
But it was really hard. No one had one ...
With Norway.
So this is the closest we'll get. You have to be Rangers, and you have to be Sweden.
That's great!
So ...
The goalie usually sits on the side!
But what are you doing? Come on!
Are you playing the round?
Sick, huh?
Oh my God!
Okay. Okay.
One.
He just steered it in there.
Here we go.
He's just trying to stall the time now!
I don't think you're that good?
But this isn't what we play!
And it's just like in soccer, you have to kill the time.
No!
Lovely.
Shouldn't we say that ...
These are two of the best hockey players in the world!
No!
Time's up!
Yeah!
Thank you so much!
Henke and Zucca are going to Oslo and Ullevaal stadion next summer.
And you can watch NHL matches in Stockholm in November.